we were told to ask you about one
particular position of needle called the
do one would you explain what that is
and would you do that to Conan um so do
one first I'll tell you the anatomical
location um between the anus and the
sexual organs and otherwise known as the
taint so that is yes definitely an
acupuncture Point um would I do it on
Conan um c a question what if there's
already something there oh no no what
what let's just say a a decorative ring
what a
piercing
uh and can I say what no I mean an
actual brass a trailer hitch ring well
it's actually handy for car
keys you can get you can get to the
taint real fast when you need to grab
something oh what does the what does the
acupuncture there du to a person oh good
question so in Acupuncture school we've
all had it done to us um and you know
believe it or not in the Chinese
medicine texts it says that do one will
calm the mind and I was like that's
in no way it does it kind of
does what this point does up here except
it's in the taint um it's a really
interesting experience I love that you
whispered that into a microphone except
it's in the taint I hope no one heard
that uh now wait a minute were you to um
this is getting into delicate area of
course in many ways but you know the way
a masseuse is always careful to cover
certain areas there's no way that you
can jam a needle into my taint and not
see everything isn't that right well
this is a good point but have you ever
been whack have you ever been waxed
before waxed
no well I mean like when so I have never
been I have never been waxed never
you've never been waxed no I don't think
that's something are you surprised I've
never been either yeah a little
surprised I've been whacked I know
exactly what you're talking about yeah
you you got you got to just put it out
there and then they just got to do their
thing I think she's saying that there is
a way to cover it up so it sounds like
you went to some special place I'm like
well wait let's okay we're GNA let me
let me let me uh let me try and we have
to be very careful here and very
specific Sarah are you saying that
there's a way to cover up so that the
taint can be
probed uh but you don't see other things
is that right oh yeah man on your side
you have the you have the patiently on
their side lift up the butt cheek just
like a Brazilian wax well wait a minute
Sona what you're saying that are you
sure you're going first of all where is
this is this at a warehouse and are
there's a lot of
giggling no she's she's I haven't I
haven't gotten for in a long was this
that jugal f
but say so what happened when you did go
no she's right you do get on your side
and you help that's what you describ I
said you were flayed out on the table
but that's for part of it but it's not
all of it but not the taint part not the
taint part no no that part you could be
this just
unbelievable un lay on your side I mean
I mean I I don't know I don't have one
friend who hasn't been waxed before so
this is I think only news to you're a
male friend get waxed oh no I don't have
any male friends I just have a husband
but all my friends are girls yeah I'm
just saying I think it's a I think it's
a Well guys get guys get waxed I don't
think they do below I'm getting we're
getting a thumbs down from every other
guy here okay all right guys do not get
waxed down there if anything I have more
hair put on okay all right thought I
thought some guys do I have needled a
number of
pennium and oh my God men and women I
love any story that starts that way I
love I think thinking of an old sea
champ an old guy Ben at Sea tell us old
man what I've needled many a
pennium what did you ever see any whales
no never to whale did you ever go to see
not really no but I've needled many a
penum I've used a whalebone needle on a
oh gather around ye mes uh so you've
needled a perenium and it's no big deal
no big deal not at all I wouldn't needle
yours unless you needed it so to answer
your question to bring it all back no I
would not needle your you did you did
dudes all of them had hair there or
there were some that were probably waxed
I'm guessing well that's what I was
going to say I have not actually seen a
waxed taint of a dude before all right
yeah well then you haven't truly lived
have you no come on elive waxed Tain
that's going to be the the death side
regret at 99 you're up Inland I never
saw a waxed male
taint I've seen a Sasquatch and a Yeti
but never never once and Max Tain okay
hang on Grandma we're getting we're
getting Barry in
here um she's gone uh Sarah that's
incredible you it works tell me I mean
there are some people that might
say I don't think I don't see how uh
touching these different parts of the
body with a needle could work but how
but it does work clearly it works this
has been around for a thousand years um
and uh you know there taint no reason to
say it hasn't so my
question my question is uh is
it how does it work how does it
work
this got it I I have an answer I this is
my job and I love to talk about it so
think about your brain or think about
your body as if it's made up of a bunch
of channels that run from head to toe
when there's pain or when there's stress
or when there's something that's
bothering you in Chinese medicine
because we're all acupuncturists are all
Chinese medicine doctors according to
Chinese medicine Theory when there is
pain blockage something that you know is
ailing you it means that the river that
goes from head to toe that channel that
runs through your body is blocked and
it's my job to figure out why is it
blocked bled and so that's why I would
ask you a lot of different questions
probably look at your tongue take your
pulse and your River could be blocked
because there's a dam there and river is
not and uh water isn't flowing we call
it Chi and Chinese medicine isn't
flowing the river could be blocked
because there's a dam further up the
channel or the dam could be blocked and
there's no River or there's no RI
there's nothing in the
river uh flowing down because there just
isn't any water does that make sense
yeah kind of I think have a dam but it's
hydroelectric oh that's a problem and
it's Genera no it's generating a ton of
power okay yeah yeah so um I think
that's I I think I do have a dam but
it's actually I'm profiting from it in
some weird way yes absolutely run
100%